thank you very much
ken son it's such an honor to be here
and to be the first speaker
of this series this quarter um
and uh to start i came to stanford in
as a graduate to graduate to join the
business school
and you know before stanford i was a
boring banker from tokyo
and however after spending two years on
this campus
i had a transformational experience to
pursue my passion to be an entrepreneur
today i would like to talk about the
importance of entrepreneurship
how it drives economic growth how it
helps innovation
and how technology makes your life
better then speak about a little bit
about my country japan
some signs of my emerging spirit of
entrepreneurship and how that's changing
how big companies behave
uh in this this you know changing market
so with that a little bit of
introduction as uh
kenzan already uh described but uh you
know
i was a graduate from tokyo university i
joined the uh one of the big banks in
japan
and i came to united states to join uh
stanford business school
after that i was a partner at uh one of
the sandhill venture capital call for
called the adult capital management dcm
and
this january i started a fun firm called
will
which i would explain activities later
so to kick off this presentation i would
like to start with
a story of an english teacher
i'm sure a lot of people in this room
knows
who this is so you know
a gentleman standing you know with his
arm i don't know why he's had to stretch
his arm but
talking to his 17th friend in his house
in hanzo
so he was a former english teacher
in hanzo he started a company in his
apartment
his name is jack there's a wife in that
picture and 17 friends
um they all put up their you know
savings to start a company
in a chinese company that can compete in
a global market
they contributed 60k at this company
15 years later so company was founded in
15 years later two weeks ago two fridays
ago september 2019
this company went public on new york
stock exchange
it was the largest ipo in the history of
united states
actually history of you know entire
history 20 you know
227 billion i don't know how i should
count this but
to give you the idea this is a larger
market cap is bigger than toyota
today so this company is called alibaba
maybe a lot of people may have heard
about it
and i was i wanted to start with this
story since
this is a story of a former english
teacher starting
a company with his friends 15 years ago
15 years later he created
a e-commerce empire which is valued more
than toyota today
and this one is example how
entrepreneurship mindset
could create a huge economic impact
where you can it doesn't matter where
you came from
what you do today it's all about your
passion
and your spirit to change the world and
if you stack up alibaba against some of
the well-known
high-tech companies it's already you
know above facebook
and you know oracle and samsung and
intel
and you know a lot of people heard about
alibaba but when you see this picture
you realize how big this company is
so entrepreneurship is so important
look at these logos i'm sure most of you
in this room
must be the user of these technologies
these are all born in silicon valley
that's why we should care about
entrepreneurship and startups
so now let's step back and talk a little
bit about why
do we need star runs
let me start with some numbers
so this number means less than
point two percent of something
becomes twenty one percent and
so point two percent so this represent a
venture capital annual venture capital
investment in the united states
uh compared to gdp of the united states
it's less than uh 0.2
it's it's actually about 0.1 right now
but it's creating over 20
of gdp value what does it mean
with a small investment it creates huge
economic value to our society
and this is why i wanted this topic
matter to us
that when you have an emerging uh when
you have a mature country
looking for growth venture is one of the
few areas that you can drive a huge
growth in your economy
let's look at different number now so
0.2 percent
now you know what this number is becomes
eleven percent
so now this is you know venture-backed
startups
if you add a job created by venture
venture-backed startups it equals
roughly 11
again these numbers could change a
little bit but the point is
with small investment is creating a lot
of jobs
and this is another point that we
discussed a lot about you know when we
talk about high-tech
industry people say oh it doesn't create
a lot of jobs it doesn't replace
traditional industries
but when you really look at the numbers
it's not you know
it's not necessarily what people think
it is actually creating a lot of jobs
for us
and what are these jobs look like again
this is just an example
of some of the public information that i
could acquire
so googling um you know the numbers on
the left-hand side of
each logo are the number of employees
when these companies went public
on the right hand side these are the
numbers of current employees based on
their website
so obviously companies like home depot
starbucks
you know with a lot of shops no surprise
it creates a lot of jobs
you know but even you know apple and
google it creates you know meaningful
job
particularly in this bay area so to
encourage more entrepreneurship
to build on the next google the next
facebook
it really adds a lot of employment
opportunities
and makes our community very vibrant
so now let's look at some different
stats
so these are you know a number of
companies
and a dollar spent by each corporation
with the logo um this past 15 years
on mnas what do you mean by m a
so you think about cisco oracle
microsoft google they can do everything
by their own they have infinite amount
of money
they have a lot of employees but the
reality is these companies acquire these
companies
these startups to make you know to keep
innovation going for instance google
just looking at some of the reported
stats acquired more than
close to 30 companies already this year
facebook
i think 15 or 20 this year so google
who everyone thinks have so many
services in fact they're the most
aggressive acquirers of these startups
and that is driving their innovation and
that makes this in the silicon valley
community very very exciting
so another angle to look at this
is you know this innovation led by
startups
changes how we live now i listed some of
the services
or companies or products that doesn't
exist just 10 years ago
and you know when i say 10 yes it's 10
years ago
and i i often forget that how i started
with my really ugly cell phone but now
everyone uses smartphone i guess
in stanford campus and everyone is so
used to looking at tesla which is not
a common car anywhere in other parts of
the world but in silicon valley tesla is
everywhere in safeway and trader joe's
and
it feels very awkward but you know this
is a very special place
and everyone uses gmail for their emails
and everyone is on
facebook i guess to communicate with
your friends to find your old friends
from 30 years ago
and these are but you know none of these
technology existed 10 years ago
so you know we should realize how
powerful
these startups are to change their lives
easier better
and you know and but because of these
tools we get to meet people
that you would never have met if these
didn't exist
so what do you think is going to happen
10 years from now
here are the technologies that could
potentially happen
not you don't have to wait maybe 10
years maybe in five years these things
will be available
one in the upper corner here the cute
little car
is a self-driving car by google this
actually car doesn't have a driver
so basically if you tell this car to go
to this place
this car will ship your kid to your
soccer field or this
car will go to your daughter's school to
pick up them
at high school and it could change how i
guess
a lot of your wife spend their time you
know driving their kids and spending so
much time just
you know chauffeuring uh a lot of part
of their life i guess
another example is this flying drones it
looks like a helicopter
but this is already uh you know on the
in the field testing by you know ups
and fedex think about these helicopters
flying into your front door and dropping
a medicine when you need
right now this technology is already
available
and we're waiting for from regulatory
changes
and in the best use case and obviously
has to be a viable business
to keep going obviously space your
traveling is closed you know
also these sensor devices that can tell
you whether you're healthy condition or
not
there's so many technologies that people
dreamed about
which is already very close to being
real
and again these technologies are not
necessarily driven by
a big companies it's driven by sometime
by a few individuals with entrepreneur
spirit
oftentimes it's a lot of people from
this campus i guess
so just to summarize all the data i just
showed you
it was to you know to make a point why
we need startups
in our community it creates a lot of
economic value as i mentioned
it creates jobs and also it accelerates
innovation
you know and it adds a lot of pressure
to big companies because big companies
you know
needs to innovate and drive the economy
as well and finally
it transformed how we live our life
so now let's look at this data
relative to you know the situation in
japan
and and and talk a little bit about how
japan can be more entrepreneurial since
that's a big
topic that you know a professor kanji is
also working on
on today
and i want to start with some stats here
as well
so now 0.7 billion dollars
versus 39 billion dollars
so 0.7 billion 700 million dollars this
is
uh if you look at how much venture
capital
invested in startups this past 12 months
uh in japan 700 million dollar was
invested
when while u.s and more than half of
this is in silicon valley
40 billion dollars so it's 57x gap it's
a simple math
there's a big gap between how much risk
money is provided in japan and how much
it is spent here in the united states
and also in u.s there is a very
convenient set of people called angels
a lot of them live in this area and they
spent about 20 billion
almost every year to fund these startups
so if you add that up in the 39 billion
dollars
again simple math not super accurate
but you would see 90 x gap between the
risk money provided to
new japanese entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurs who come to silicon valley
or united states
so there's still a huge gap i guess
so the next step 400 billion dollars
19 billion dollars these numbers are too
big i don't even know what that means
but uh
so 100 billion this is a market cap of
google two weeks ago
and 90 billion dollars this is a
numbers total of all the internet
companies in japan very famous ones and
i think i
chose companies with over a billion
dollar market cap so
basically big companies that a lot of
japanese have heard of or known or
or hear about but if you add all this
company
the google one company cannot just is so
much bigger than these companies that
represent japan so when you live in
japan
you think yahoo japan or rakuten they
dominate the entire tech space
or they are the largest company that you
know you can even think of but once you
come to united states
you see a you know behemoths like google
that can easily buy entire companies on
this list
and that's still again a gap between u.s
and japan in total so now a different
stat
430 billion dollars and 90 billion
dollars so 90 billion dollars the same
number all the you know tech companies
that represent japan today
now a lot of people say google is unfair
because it's a normally
those companies only emerge once every
thousand years so i
took out google forget google and let's
see any
the companies that are formed after year
again queen number it's been it's not
even 15 years yet
very young companies if you add all the
market cap of these
companies in this logo it adds up to 430
billion
which is beyond google and again i just
wanted to remind you
that google is not the only one
we're seeing a lot of companies who is
chasing after google who wants
who's making a huge impact in our
community
and at one day i think one of these
companies will become
a huge business that would impact all of
us in this room
okay now going back another number
400 billion and 890 billion
google okay
now if you add the top 10 market cap
companies in japan
i'm glad that google is smaller than
this
i would be very ashamed i would but i
would not be standing here
it's going to be so hard to make you
excited about japan
if this number was smaller so i'm glad
so you know but you know these are
traditional companies toyota
honda you know ntt um kddi
banks these are companies that existed
you know
i don't know forever i guess not new
companies
so you know google once one company
google cannot compete with them
so now let's look at different number
so top 10 companies in japan today
traditional companies
now if i cut off this
market cap line at 99.95
which is a year when netscape went
public and yahoo went public
the starting of the internet era in the
united states or in the world
when you add the market cap it beats all
the best companies in japan
so i don't know it's one trillion
dollars i guess
and this is a power of startup
and again let's not forget that these
companies didn't exist you know 20 years
ago
these are relatively young companies and
startup by
a lot of them are started by stanford
students and a lot of them are startup
by non-tech people and
it's always amazing everyone thinks
startup is only available for people
with high iq and great grades and and
all the
you know people who can program
computers and know about
you know a lot of semiconductors but
it's not
anyone in this room can be one of this
you know one of the entrepreneurs who
can
lead these companies like that
so another different step slightly
different
from our previous slides
so in japan you know the previous stats
would say
well you know there's a lot of big
companies in japan that means
there must be a lot of dollars and
obviously a lot of venture capital was
spent in united states so
even though i'm trying to encourage
entrepreneurship in japan how do i
finance them
what are the sources of capital to
drive these innovations and when i look
at the stat
so r d budget that big company in japan
spends
in every year so this is a budget that
was posted on nikkei
for budget for 2013. you know toyota
is spending nine billion dollars a year
almost every year
on r d you know again a lot of them are
you know
building their current cars remodeling
cars
and i'm sure some part of that is spent
to you know create their version of
tesla electronic vehicle or hydrogen
power
cars but the problem is
like this picture uh you know
describes a lot of the research project
are all sourced
to their purpose and it's all spent
internally and it's in a technical it's
called
closed innovation style basically doing
everything by their own
spending every dollar for yourself not
for mna or not for investing into
startups
so when i look at these numbers i said
geez you know japan has a lot of money
all these big companies
who i think is all dead or really
screwed up
has so much money to spend yet
they're just mindset is so narrow and
how you know
i wish they were spending even one
percent or five percent or ten percent
of this budget
into helping startups or acquiring
companies because that would allow them
to accelerate their innovation
and then come up with cool products
because they you know i think a lot of
people in this room know these brands
and they still have a lot of brands with
a lot of history and legacy
but you know these you know legacy is
diminishing very fast today
okay let's look at now different stat
so you know we i'm here to talk about
entrepreneurship and why it's important
and i happened to do a same speech
same day about 14 hours ago in tokyo i
just landed today in san jose and i was
making the same speech to a different
university in japan
but you know in japan everyone is
interested about entrepreneurship but
when you look at this stat
okay business school where i graduated
so
percent of graduate in 2006 not 10 years
ago but you know
uh long ago uh who went to the tech and
entrepreneur sector was 20
today you know as we obviously we know
silicon valley is it's you know a lot of
hype and excitement around
entrepreneurship
everyone wants to become an entrepreneur
from this number i i just had
a 10-year reunion i think two years ago
obviously who were there more than half
of the people in my classmate
were entrepreneurs so it tells how
powerful
the entrepreneurship the spirit of
entrepreneurship is in silicon valley
and
also i just listed harvard also people
at harvard
wants to become an entrepreneur which is
quite surprising i thought every harvard
people go to ge or ibm
so you know it's it's uh it's amazing
that everyone in the united states wants
to become an entrepreneur today
so let's look at tokyo university where
people think that the best and brightest
go
so 10 10 percent and and in fact if
i if i break down this number it's
majority it includes tech and
entrepreneur
so i think the number of entrepreneur is
less than one percent
and despite all this excitement
the number hasn't changed much so
you know this is why i want to think
about how can we change the mentality of
students or how can i change the
mentality of society to embrace
entrepreneurship
such that the number would look more
like stanford or harvard
in the next 10 years i think if japan
cannot change
how people think japan will never become
a startup nation
so to summarize all the numbers i showed
you uh
basically goes to these four points uh
first of all
obviously a big gap in risk capital lack
of risk capital in the society
and and lack of mega ventures you know
we think a lot of these japanese
companies are big and famous
but in terms of economic value they're
still very small
relative to even one company like google
and obviously from some of the stats i
showed you japanese big companies
are very close relative to silicon
valley it's very
open we call it the open innovation
style so disclose corporate cultures
really prevent startup emerging in the
society
and finally entrepreneurship joining
entrepreneur becoming an entrepreneur or
jumping into a unknown company is
never encouraged or not respected you
know even if you try to
join a company after you graduate from
tokyo university first of all your
parents going to go against it and then
your grandma was going to show up in
your room and said
you know just don't go to this dinky
startup and just go to
mitsubishi or mitsui or whatever you
know company that they know and that's
the reality of japan today
okay so am i here to just you know talk
about
negatives not really so
i want to share a little bit about what
i do day to day and what are the signs
bright signs that i see in the japanese
community today
which makes me believe that 10 years
from now japan could look
very different from what i showed
the first sign is the government
the government is trying to push
entrepreneurship like
crazy this time it's not even like joke
it's just
every minister minister of economic
trade in industries
ministry of education ministry of
communication ministry of education
everyone is pushing entrepreneurship
everyone is encouraging
students to you know young kids to even
you know people in the mid 40s mid 50s
who are stuck in big companies
try entrepreneurship there's not a lot
of risk but like you think
and that's a good thing and government
is going to support you financially
and mentally and as a you know as a
facility they're going to give you a lot
of resource
to do that and i think this is a very
promising sign
you know bits and pieces of this
happened in the past
but this time a lot of our ministry are
joining forces
to push entrepreneur entrepreneurship
big time in japan
and you know it's sad i mean this should
be led by private sector by the way but
unfortunately in japan since these big
companies are
really risk averse uh government who i
thought was the most conservative people
in the world
is now becoming very aggressive which is
a good sign and i think there's some
people in this room who are from the
government
secondly okay corporates are not done
there are some aggressive corporations
who is trying to embrace
corporate venture capital activities the
corporate venture capital for those who
you don't know much about
so again majority of the corporation
when you talk about innovation
or entrepreneurship they try to do all
in health they fund
their entrepreneurs in they we in japan
we call in us we call it entrepreneurs
so entrepreneurial
people in your big companies they try to
do everything on their own
but these companies that are listed are
companies who set up a separate fund
a separate setup resource or actually a
place
to host entrepreneurs and then and help
actually entrepreneurs
to become a big company and i think this
is a new trend
in the past these were done you know
in bits and pieces now we see enough
critical mass of companies
including even tv station like fuji tv
recruit you know ito chumitsu like big
trading companies
nikon very traditional japanese company
all these companies have a corporate
venture program where
they're willing to invest they're
willing to provide technical support
they're willing to provide spaces and
i think this is a great sign that
corporations are now
trying to at least trying to become a
little more open than before
the another corporate trend and we're
seeing a lot more m
a activities these are still you know
rakuten softbank ntt these are still
companies that a lot of people in japan
think is very progressive thinkers but
again
if you look at the number of m a's they
have done this past
i guess this one is five years
you know i'm sure a lot of people in
this room is quite surprised
we think mna is all done by google or
facebook or all these western
silicon valley based companies so now
japanese is coming back
i'm sure a lot of people were surprised
when softbank one of the japanese
carriers acquired sprint networks and
they even tried to acquire t-mobile
so i think this trend will continue
japan with a big company's resource and
now
you know with a strong leadership is
embracing entrepreneurship
and one way to achieve it is to acquire
companies
outside of japan
okay another good sign in japan
so these are uh startup companies i'm
sure a lot of people in this room
have never heard about these companies
but i just picked companies
who raised more than 10 million dollars
since 2013. so a little bit over a year
why is it important ten years ago when
you talk about venture funding in japan
it was always typically around one or
two million dollars that was the big
funding most companies would fund half a
million dollars
three hundred thousand dollars and then
every investor would
force them to go public after the
financing event
so what does it mean so when you have a
venture funded with
extremely small capital when they go ipo
and tokyo stock exchange
oftentimes these companies market cap
are you know 20 million dollar companies
and you don't see a lot of companies
above 100 million dollar when they go
public
and the problem about this approach is
when you have a lot of small companies
being listed these companies lose a
chance to grow fast because once you're
listed you're under a lot of scrutiny
a lot of analysts is going to ask you
all kinds of questions
a lot of day trader is trying to trade
on your stock and you have
no flexibility to start something new
so when that was a traditional approach
of
funding startups even though we see a
lot of ipo numbers going up
it was all small companies and none of
them are even
in my chart on my previous chart so
i was always talking about 10 years ago
when i used to you know
i'm still doing this but while i travel
to japan every month
i say hey startup needs to raise more
money and just
wait before you go ipo just create
a strong foundation such that even after
you go public
you can take more risks and you can
create jobs and you can be
a 10 billion dollar plus company because
if you don't become a big company
it doesn't create a lot of social impact
and and no one
none of these big companies would even
care about you
so these larger funding rounds the
increasing number of large
larger funding realms this is
unprecedented in japan
is an extremely good sign for p person
like myself
who is trying to create uh this venture
ecosystem much more vibrant and
and dynamic
um a few more slides um
we're seeing a lot more entrepreneurs
rising rising or
more becoming more visible in our
community um
some people may may not know but you
know founder ceo of rakuten mikhiroshi
megitani
he lives in silicon valley yeah um he
has a health big huge house in silicon
valley he's going to start living there
half of his time very soon a line
is murikawa akira
this is a most popular social network
service in asia
today dna game company in lifenet
insurance company gurusi
news curation company mixi one of the
first very first social network
google public these people are becoming
much
more visible figure in japan and
and some of them are the idols the role
models for younger entrepreneurs who
want to pursue entrepreneurship
before then we were still talking about
mr honda
i don't know when he was born but you
know and and morita who started sony
and and you know it's just it was not
right
in my mind so another thing
again i'm here at stanford so i have to
put a lot of stanford
logos here startup founded by top
university alumni
this is also very encouraging too i
graduated from tokyo university none of
these companies existed
now there's so many alumni from my
school
starting these companies some of them
are public and some of them are big
enough to create
a very meaningful impact in the society
not as big as
obviously stanford you know once again
if you look at stanford
i'm sure everyone in this room must feel
very good about this you know you can be
one of them very soon
so to summarize
my data so far so japan's venture
ecosystem is not dead it's changing
and here are the positive trends we're
seeing a lot of government funding
government you know and trying to push
entrepreneurship
and we're seeing a lot of corporate
venture activities uh you know
obviously a lot of companies are putting
money into startups
and the other approach is mna you know
rakuten softbank
acquiring companies in silicon valley
acquire companies in europe
which is a good sign of open innovation
and also startups again this isn't
particularly important for us like
us venture capitalists who is trying to
help people people
you know pursue bigger companies they're
looking for larger exit
we're seeing a lot of syrian
entrepreneurs who has done this before
who is successful or who made a lot of
mistake in the past but
have a lot of lesson learned from that
and these people are coming into
this entrepreneurship ecosystem and and
that's a great sign
of uh you know if you think about what's
going to happen 10 years from now
this this is all great signs and finally
entrepreneurs again yes your grandma and
grandpa is going to try to stop you
but uh you know entrepreneurship is
becoming a cool thing
which is good thing so
10 looking 10 years from now what are we
new what do we
you know what do we need beyond all
these good signs that i saw
so far i just presented so far i think
there are three areas
that i'm trying to emphasize through my
actually my company world innovation lab
one is
leveraging resources in big companies as
i showed you in some stats
in japan yes government has a lot of
money
which is our tax money obviously but
big corporation have a lot of savings
from their success in the past we need
to unlock those capital we also need to
unlock a lot of talents
who are sitting inside of sony who are
sitting inside of toyota
because you know they're getting bored
about whether where the company is going
and they have a lot of technologies that
are hidden in their closet and they
never give it to anyone
i think we need to unlock these three
elements you know talent
technology and capital that is sitting
inside of these big corporations
and secondly again when people talk
about entrepreneurship
in japan today a lot of entrepreneurs
approach
this venture ecosystem as if it's the
shortest way to become rich very fast
that's not the right approach by doing
it
you know as a means of becoming rich
people wants to go ipo fast therefore
the company is not going to be big
it's not going to be there a long time
and it doesn't really
create any map and reasons in the
society we need to see more mega
ventures
big companies that is trying to impact
the society big ventures who is trying
to solve
the issues that we face today and i
think
if we cannot build these new form of
ventures
i think japanese venture ecosystem will
be irrelevant to the global market
10 years from now and finally
you know i'm trying to change we're in
the business
setup but fostering entrepreneurship
mindset in the entire society including
our kids including
even teachers including politicians that
has to eventually happen in a community
to make sure that entrepreneurship is
everywhere in japan
so i started a company called will world
innovation lab this january
so i'm still a startup today to do
the to actually drive these three points
that i just made earlier
so our mission is to drive open
innovation large corporation
so again open innovation is a style
where
big companies try to embrace
entrepreneurship
if you want to build a cool product
don't do everything by yourself
bring in cool entrepreneurs work with
other companies work with younger people
at stanford
that's how you come up with cool
technology and new services
today secondly
in educating entrepreneurs to think big
this
is a big theme in japan as i mentioned
earlier in japan
a lot of people approach
entrepreneurship to become rich quick
again not everyone but a lot of them
think that way
we have to people like myself who is
here to help venture as a venture
capitalist trying to help entrepreneurs
have to push the boundary don't go
public too soon
if you go public you have to be big
enough to make a meaningful impact in
the society
to create jobs and be respected by the
society
otherwise being public you're going to
have a miserable life
you've got to be under a lot of scrutiny
sec is going to chase after you
and oftentimes they screw up and they go
up and you know they end up being in the
jail so
i say it's not worth it so
entrepreneurship education is extremely
important and thinking big
is what is missing in japanese
entrepreneurship ecosystem
thirdly promoting entrepreneurship in
the society
again i talked about this
how many hours ago i forgot 15 hours ago
in japan
a lot of people said again forget it
education system in japan is so anal
it's just so hard to move even changing
a one word in textbook
it's gonna take 10 years again just
forget it and move on
you know that's a good thing no one's
going to try this so i hope i can try
this it's going to take a lot of time
and energy
but if i can't change how people think
even school teachers
our kids think about how they live their
life
my mission is not going to be successful
so to do these three things
i went after all these companies in this
logo here
sony you know nissan a airline company
telco company ntt musical bank where i
came from
diver securities hakodo advertisement
company
jvc audio company mitsukoshi in a retail
department store
credit card company educational company
i told them hey
i want to change i want to make these
changes in japan i want to change how
you guys drive innovation in your
organization
invest in my company and i will help you
achieve that
so as of now these are my partners
who invested uh close to 350 million
dollar
into my company so they obviously
invested a huge check
in my cap in my company as a capital
and if i were a traditional venture
capital
i stopped there and i just run to invest
and try to invest and make money and try
to become rich
that's a traditional venture capital but
i said i'm going to do more two more
things
one is talent you guys have a lot of
talent in your company
they're looking for something new
otherwise they're gonna
leave and they're gonna join apple
they're gonna join google that's waste
of your resource you trained them
and they were happy employees at sony
and why are you letting them go to your
competitors
instead of doing that have them come to
my office
i would help them change their life and
drive innovation
and hopefully those proceeds would go
back to these organizations
and i said there that's a much better
use of people even though they still
leave to google by the way
which i think a lot of them will i want
to
create another system to recycle these
people
who has a lot of value who has a lot of
skills and who has a lot of
entrepreneurship mindset
and so that's what i'm also doing here
in silicon valley so i have an office
in university avenue just right across
the street from stanford
in the corner building where i host
expats and also uh short-term interns
from these corporations
uh since they're my investors and and
major partners to drive this uh project
and thirdly i also said by the way
you guys have so much technologies that
are sitting in these shelves
and i wonder why you guys are not using
it i said oh i can't
you know this is our ip you know we're
paying l
loyalty every year but we don't know
what to do with it but we don't want to
give this to samsung because they might
make
more money out of this this is silly by
the way
they're spending hundreds of millions of
dollars just trying to keep
securities patents which doesn't create
any value these are all cost
for big companies like sony or ntt or n
a or
or like nissan and i said this is silly
you know
if i look at this prototype product or
some product they think they failed 10
years ago
it has a huge value think of ibo
which sony introduced maybe about 10
years ago it was a
robot with a lot of intelligence into it
it was a dog robot which walks around
your house
and you can talk to them it moves as you
know today in silicon valley
every robot company gets funded a lot of
venture capitalists on san diego would
throw you tens of millions of dollars
just to fund these cool robot companies
when you go to sonia and say hey let's
revive
ibo they said oh we failed this project
we cannot revive this guy
so i said okay let's change the name you
know bible or you know cyborg or
whatever
i'll start a new company you know you
guys have a great technology and
you still keep the ip why don't i spend
that out and
and make a new cool startup in silicon
valley not even in tokyo
that's what i call carvel it's not
just about sony every big company even
in us
must have a lot of hidden stuff in their
closet
i want to unlock them such that these
new cool technologies
which are built by these engineers
creates a social impact
so what we do at will we we have these
funding and support from this big
corporation
we we claim ourselves as a change agent
change agent for these big companies we
drive their innovation
we drive their entrepreneurship and
and the business we do are three things
one is we call it investment
this is basically acting as a corporate
venture arm
you know you know my ideal goal is sony
or these companies to do corporate
venture capital program
internally such that they can work with
startups directly
however a lot of my partners never
done these activities so they don't know
anything about venture capital
investment
so i'm asking as their proxy
to help them potentially build a
incorporal venture program in the future
for the time being they invest in me
and i invest in cool technology startups
that could be relevant
to each of my partners the second part
of business we call it as a business
creation
this is some project that i just kind of
mentioned spending out some of the
assets or even
incubating a business together with some
of my partners you know
we incubation is really hot still in
silicon valley and a lot of you know
even stanford has incubation program
from startx
off campus and i think it's a great
thing but the problem about
incubation from scratch is this it just
takes so much time
and it's not very easy the success ratio
of incubation is very low
so i said well these big companies
already have
a people with 15 years 20 year
experience building semiconductors
building softwares why don't i incubate
with them they have all the technical
capabilities they just don't know how to
package it
as a independent business or sometimes
they're just not aware about how much
value they have
so my team at will will go into these
big companies identify some of the
technologies or engineers
who who has the entrepreneurship mindset
and i spend that out and i fund those
projects through our fund
and try to create a viable independent
business and that's what we call
business creation
and the third part is i call it
education
so my ultimate goal is to make these
companies independently successful
as a company that is driving innovation
right now
the i partner with them to help them
create
this venture program internally so for
the next 10 years
because of this funding i'm trying to
educate their these entrepreneurs these
uh
employees who is lucky enough to
come to our space uh you know as an
intern or expat
and do these activities you know
activity one and two
in corporate venturing activities to
business incubation actually
together with my team and i think it's
always better
it's you know and i'm hoping to send
some students to kenzan
to you know become more entrepreneurial
and use this stanford campus
to you know brainwash them to become
entrepreneurs i guess
but uh i think ultimately education is
most important for the long-term
impact because unless people change
their mindset nothing really happened
so this is kind of how my company's uh
you know vision is i have an office here
at university avenue and also
office in tokyo roppongi in tokyo and
trying to connect
this large corporation world to the
startup ecosystem
and by connecting these thoughts i hope
i can you know i can stimulate this
japanese entrepreneurship
ecosystem so that again ten years from
now
a lot of the numbers and stats that i
show you would look very different
so finally i would like to end my speech
with uh one marketing actually
ad which i really like um which i wanted
to share with you
and uh without more words let's
start
here's to the crazy ones the misfits
the rebels the troublemakers
the round pegs in the square holes
the ones who see things differently
they're not fond of rules and they have
no respect for the status quo
you can quote them disagree with them
glorify or vilify them
about the only thing you can't do is
ignore them
because they change things they push the
human race forward
while some may see them as the crazy
ones
we see genius
because the people who are crazy enough
to think they can change the world
are the ones who do
so i hope people in this room is crazy
enough to change the world
thank you very much
i i really like uh will's idea the ideal
music japanese innovation is very strong
this may not be his really point that he
would like to talk
but completion about government growth
and japanese government role is very
strongly
putting out money but this is the major
difference between silicon valley and
japan
so i really want to know what the
governance should be
in japan instead of just pulling out
money giving up money
which may not be starting
what do you think yeah i think the point
uh matusan was making was in japan
again government is becoming
aggressively supportive of
entrepreneurship is a good thing
but i think for a lot of public people's
mind it looks like government is just
throwing money at everything
which could end up becoming a major
disaster of loss in our tax dollars so
what do you think is the ideal way for
government to support entrepreneurship
in japan
so uh in an interesting way i had the
same question from my previous
speech in japan everyone says oh
government is just doing way way too
much
and they're just going to lose all the
money and they shouldn't be coming into
the entrepreneurship
i i think you know ideally once again i
said
you know private sector should be
driving innovation and pushing and
providing more risk money
but since japanese corporation despite
they talk about
open innovation they talk about what do
we do with all these cash that we
accrued over you know tens of twenties
of years
no one is taking risks obviously it has
to do with in how
this ranking system in japan works you
know see
and every ceo gets kicked out every few
years and they didn't want to take risks
to make that period shorter so uh that's
that's the fact
what i proposed to the government people
for who are in my room in the previous
us when i was in tokyo
is that i think government support is
good but
government just throwing money at
startup is not a good idea because they
never
you know there are all people who never
done business they don't know anything
about entrepreneurship
and they don't even know who are the
good entrepreneurs so
what happens they all throw money to
people
who basically you know approaches
and who are friends of government
officials who
you know they who looks good which are
not necessarily the best entrepreneurs
in my mind
so what is a good solution i i told the
government official who asked this
question that
the government should still you know
provide be part of this risk money
ecosystem however it should be at least
matched by the private sector money so
if the startup comes to the government
and asks for 10 million investment
at least he or she should get funding
for private venture capital or
corporations
at least 10 million or 20 million so the
government can match 100
or half of the money that they actually
got from the private sector people who
knows about business
but if the government is throwing money
at people who cannot raise money from
these private sectors
you're doing something completely wrong
that's what i told them
and unfortunately that is what's
happening in japan today so i i really
need to stop this
from becoming a disaster so i think
government
government support is good and but
eventually their role should diminish
very fast but for the time being this is
a chicken and egg problem
or cash 22 you know if there's not
enough risk money
they can become you know the first step
but eventually it has to be covered by
the private sector
small companies in japan and my
experience i totally agree with you that
uh japanese just don't like risk no risk
money that makes sense
um at the small companies though all the
risk ended up
being burdened on the shoulders of the
founders
so the funders the vcs that funded like
have low risk the burden was really on
the founders their their personal
i don't know their car right so
it looks like you've got a business
model which is fantastic it's refreshing
because it's a
lower risk it looks like it's lower risk
for companies to get together and use
you
yes do you offer better term sheets than
they would than companies in japan would
get from
traditional yes um couple activities
that we're doing is to try and
certain these bad business customs like
you said
every time a start mid to small size
business gets funded oftentimes the ceo
the founder
everything that he or she has get
collateralized even your kids say you
know
education you know school savings and
everything it's just a disaster i've
seen so many bankrupted comp you know
friends who are very unhappy
so first step government actually is
going to make those
you know very strict uh those
collateralization uh
illegal so that's a good thing so a lot
of people can
take risk without risking entire you
know uh
fortune or asset you have today that's a
good thing and also venture capital term
sheet
i said these you know buyback stock
buyback
plans and these silly terms that i put a
lot of load onto the entrepreneurs
i said we're going to get rid of those
things and we're going to make data
industry standard
and obviously i'm going to have to fight
with traditional vcs but
you know that's how silicon valley
entrepreneurship is encouraged
you know venture capitalists take the
risk and if we lose money
we move on we're not going to try to
chase after the entrepreneur until
you know he gets miserable and that's a
very wrong approach
they should have a second chance they
should have a third chance they should
have 10th chance
that's the healthy entrepreneurship you
know in community
so these things are changing i think
regulatory uh people know about these
issues and uh yeah as
a as well we are trying to do the right
thing
uh in the us most venture funds get
investment from you know lps that are
pension funds places that are really
focused on return
on their investment your investors seem
to be primarily corporate do they have a
different motivation or
have different expectations around
return and more
that they're asking for as a lp in your
fund or how are you
how are you uh dealing with that that's
a great question
so yes traditional venture capitalists
where i used to work for 10 years
there are three sources of fund it's
fundal funds who are people who collect
a lot of you know a lot of money from
high net worth individuals
basically rich peoples and invest
allocate
to a lot of assets second one is pension
fund like dow jones you know ge
these big corporations have a pension
program for their employees
third one is endowment like stanford
stanford has a huge
uh stanford management company has a
huge fund to invest in venture capital
these three people in a short way
they only care about returns right they
invest your one dollar if you get three
dollar back they're happy and they're
going to keep your financing
corporate investors are very tricky like
my previous firm used to avoid corporate
investors oh i guess most of the santel
road vcs avoid corporate investors
because
money is not their priority they always
ask for business strat
and business synergies or strategic
value which i don't really know what
what it means
obviously they want to know more about
startups they want to
do want to get meaningful information
that they feel it was beneficial
and these are tricky because as a
venture capitalist you're dealing with
these startups who want to
do things in a stealth mode or they
don't want to share too much information
because
they always fear what if they copied the
business model or they copy the
technology and run away
so it doesn't work so from my ten year
experience
there must be a healthy mechanism to
bridge between these startup ecosystem
big companies
and that's why i strategically focused
on these corporate money
instead of pension money which in some
cases it's easier because as you're a
good fund manager
they would throw money at you without
asking a lot of questions a lot
without asking a lot of your time but
the reason why i ask corporate money
is because this project is not about
building a huge fund
this project is all about educating
people
and spinning out these technologies or
invested you know invested
house in these big companies and
unlocking them
again everyone in this room must know
everyone
might think it's impossible because this
big company has so many corporate walls
but i'm trying it and it's been you know
10 months
and i see some signs of success so i
hope i can keep on doing this for 10
years and
and see what happens
um so you're saying that you want to
unlock the corporate technology which
has been larger
corporations who do you find to actually
do the spin-off work like the technology
development
uh some of that because if you invest in
other startups
those stars are busy with their own jobs
yes they're not going to want to work on
other projects yes so
who who does that kind of light work uh
who does the legwork after you spend
that oh
that's a great question so uh technical
expertise often comes from these tech
companies manufacturing companies like
sony or nissan and then
whoever runs business will be perhaps
you
which we recruit so as it will what
we're doing on the other hand while we
negotiate the spin out
we're also huddling the management team
who will be leading these technologies
these tech companies so when you're in
the process
oftentimes our team will be act we'll be
acting like a ceo of this
project and and while we're talking
and this spin-up discussion as you can
imagine takes a lot of time because the
legal department is going to come in
and the lecture property department is
coming and lastly
human you know human resource department
say i can't let this guy go out you know
because this is
this is a star star engineer and i can't
give you this guy i have to deal with
all these corporate
you know hurls but i mean while i do
that i go out and recruit people
who can run this business um as a
management team
so that's another layer of business that
i and i didn't elaborate
all today equity or is that yeah
that's a great question so as a
structure i finance this project
so as well we become the largest equity
holder
and uh and the originator of this
technology on
some portion of it and i'm hoping i
issue stock optional sub-incentive to
the people who is going to join this
entity
so that was an amazing presentation and
actually gives you a lot of hope i've
visited japan
it's amazing to see there is a
tremendous creative spirit that's there
but in the last couple years i've
noticed you know i've hosted a couple
dozen japanese friends
in my home in palo alto have come to
visit and experience silicon valley
and one of the questions that a few of
them have brought up over and over again
is
that in japan we have such a an amazing
culture around meticulous engineering
around a really special design and how
to
preserve the things that make japanese
great while also making a transition to
you know to a more risky or mis risk
tolerant i should say you know uh
society
and a great example would be there's a
book that was written by james balos
called more like us and it was written
in response to a lot of americans in the
1980s thought
japanese companies are being so much
more successful than we are
how can we be more like them and james
fallow said japanese companies to be
great
have to take what's great about japan
and make it better
we can learn from each other and
americans take what's great about
america
so what what can you do to preserve that
special culture in japan
and while while still bringing this
culture the risk cultures you have
that's a great question i hope i know
the answer to it but let me try to
answer them
so some of the there are a lot of
elements we don't know about japan so
uh i was looking at so you know when i
have time i look at my facebook feeds
and one feat
that i looked recently only i think 77
percent of japanese don't even have a
passport
so you know you realize japan is very
you know people we see
a lot of japanese on staff for campus
and all we see you know every japanese
must be traveling a lot but the reality
is
very few japanese even have overseas
experience
within let's say if that number is true
within that 20 some percent
of people uh need to be entrepreneurial
in my mind it's not about
about entrepreneurship mindset is
important i wish every japanese is born
to try something new and think
differently than what it is today
but whoever is going to lead the society
as a strong entrepreneur like son from
softbank
i don't think we need hundreds of people
we just need not maybe five more
sunshine that's what i told in the
previous piece
we talked about oh we need thousands of
people
to become a huge you know big
entrepreneur that's
i said forget it it's not going to
happen in our culture we just need
very few people to make our society more
exciting
and dynamic such that young people have
hope
and and again it's my point was not to
ask all people in sony to jump out of
sony and start new companies
they can still be part of sony but they
need to think differently they just have
to become
entrepreneur you know and not go to
office every day and sit and
and ask what should i do today to spend
my next nine hours and
and that's that's what's killing these
japanese corporations
so i think my ideal goal is
hopefully there is at least a top level
management you know there are limited
number of board seats obviously in big
companies these people need to change
the mindset
if they are willing to take risk even
though some of the projects they may
take on
could shorten their life as a ceo
i think that's you know they have to
think i did something new
and i got kicked out from the ceoc but i
don't regret it because i
give it a shot i just want to create a
corporate culture that
even though this big company exhibited
make a big bet on new things and fail
peop some parts of the society would
appreciate those challenges
and i may ask them to become a ceo of my
startup
so i want these people to be kicked out
actually by taking this
so uh that's kind of my my thinking
right now
you had mentioned it would be great if
some of the children would be brought up
with this innovative
entrepreneurial mindset could you speak
to education and how
educators could actually steer some of
that mindset change
yeah so um again
if you think about changing the
education system per se
you know i think silicon valley has a
great education very entrepreneurial
educational system even
my kids live in palo alto and they all
go to public school here
it's just so different from how kids are
born and raised
in you know public school in japan and
if i try to change that
again it's gonna take probably 20 30
years or even
forever to change it so i said what is
the most effective way to change how our
kids
think about entrepreneurship my answer
today
is to show them what it's so the parents
need to be changed
that was my first reaction i said i i
get asked by a lot of parents how can i
make my kid
entrepreneurial how can i make my kid go
to stanford i said
you have to change first you have to be
an entrepreneur you have
to embrace risk you have to do something
new because you know
all your kids are always looking at you
they're not looking at teachers every
day they always look at you
how you spend time how you do things and
if you're always afraid of doing new
things if you are always afraid of
let's say even wearing different clothes
or even you know going
camping which you never have done your
kids is never gonna take risk
you you as a parent have to do things
differently
do things you know try new things and
that's how you
make your kids entrepreneurial and i
think that's the most effective
and most low-hanging fruit that a lot of
people in this room may
may not may or may not know of i think
there is a lot of role that parents can
play
in this educational ecosystem it's not
about throwing them into stanford campus
it's not about
going to these tech camps uh on in
summer schools
it is i think it happens in your house
and it's not
and then hopefully these school teachers
would understand how to
how to encourage taking risks and how
not to punish students who made mistakes
because right now a lot of asian
educational system is based on merit
system
if you make a mistake you get punished
if you're all a
you're a good student and as long as
that paradigm exists
it's going to be extremely difficult to
encourage risk taking or doing something
different beyond your academic course
because
everyone wants to get a and if you
cannot do anything beyond
academics or you know anything that has
nothing to do with your
you know your grades they're not going
to spend any time on it and i think
changing their system hope i can change
it but i think it's going to take time
yes changing
bankruptcy laws yes would be part of the
solution
yeah right because if bankruptcy laws
are forgiving
and open to or facilitating a restart
right it's a different minor than if
bankruptcy laws are
unforgiving and penalizing
um sometimes
and that doesn't really facilitate
growth i agree so in fact
um if you look at the legal environment
today japan is one of the country where
bankruptcy process is
is one of the shortest in the world
today so the bankrupting company in
japan is becoming much more easier
it's close to it's almost identical to
how it's a bankruptcy is treated here
so from the legal point of view it's
almost the same
however the society how people look at
you after you go bankrupt is completely
different
you lose a lot of relatives right you
lose a lot of friends when you're
successful
you find a lot of relatives who you
never met
and you know that's that's kind of how
it works today so i hope that
people's mindset will change over time
you